die energiekrise klimawandel krieg man
kann schon angst vor der zukunft haben
im moment jene menschen die sich ohnehin
immer schon auf den weltuntergang
vorbereitet haben sorgen noch mal extra
vor
krieg in europa
stromausfälle in deutschland gewaltsame
aufstände und das ende der welt auf
diese krisen bereiten sich sogenannte
preppy vor constantin ist einer von
ihnen er hat das internetforum peppers
germany gegründet
betreffen constantin in seiner wohnung
in schleswig holstein seinen genauen
wohnort dürfen wir nicht zeigen oder
nennen denn konstantin hat angst in
einer krise ausgeraubt zu werden seine
wohnung ist voll mit lebensmitteln
wasser medizin und krisen ausrüstung
constantin hat sich zu beginn der korona
krise selbstständig gemacht er
programmiert und entwickelt medien
konzepte von zuhause treppe war schon
vor der korona krise ich habe mich
darauf vorbereitet dass es einen virus
buch geben könnte oder irgendwie was mit
krankheiten und
als es soweit war
war mir bewusst okay das ist das ist
real das ziel des rappers ist es ja
keine angst zu haben dafür zu sorgen
dass was auch immer man macht
einem keine angst macht wenn man
vorbereitet ist man kann etwas tun
trepper ist eine ableitung aus dem
englischen wort prepare auf deutsch
vorbereitet
constantin hat immer essen und wasser
für mindestens drei monate im haus falls
eine krise ausbricht und die supermärkte
leer geräumt werden kann er sich zu
hause selbst versorgen grundsätzlich
gibt es keine richtige feste regel wirst
du brauchst oder hauptsache du hast ganz
viel zu futtern ganz viel zu essen damit
du eine weile über die runden kommt
langfristig habe ich für mich
festgestellt es ist wichtig in der
auswahl zu haben um die moral wiederum
zu stärken braucht er viel abwechslung
aber nur ein lebensmittel vorrat reicht
nicht in einer krise
für einen möglichen stromausfall hat
sich constantin mit taschenlampen
batterien gaskocher und kerzen
eingedeckt im fall einer ausgewachsenen
krise will constantin sich zuhause
verschanzen das szenario es ist winter
wir haben kein gas keine heizung kein
strom und vor den supermärkten gibt es
aufstände weil die lebensmittel knapp
werden weil konstantin vorbereitet ist
kann er sich zurücklehnen und die krise
zumindest drei bis vier monate lang
aussetzen
er ist aber auch vorbereitet falls er
seinen zufluchtsort für einige tage
verlassen muss fackeln zelt funkgerät
und notfallrucksack stehen immer
griffbereit neben der eingangstür
was ist sozusagen das schlimmste
szenario auf das du dich auch irgendwie
vorbereitet hast das leben wir gerade
das leben wir derzeit das ist krieg in
europa der scheiße ist real die kämpfen
da drüben die zerstören ganz so heuser
ganze ganze wohnblöcke und dörfer werden
dort niedergebrannt mit irgendwelchen
bomben 1500 kilometer von der deutschen
grenze entfernt es ist uns nicht jeder
ist vorbereitet darauf unruhen unruhen
vor den supermärkten weil nahrungsmittel
oder sonstwas noch mal schnell worden
wenn der menschen nach einer woche merkt
die krise ist noch nicht vorbei dann
spätestens dann gehen die alarmglocken
bei jedem an und dann haben wir die
panik hamstern und soziale unruhen ein
szenario vor dem auch die
bundesregierung warnt auf der
offiziellen seite des bundesamtes für
bevölkerungsschutz und katastrophenhilfe
wird empfohlen lebensmittelvorräte für
zwei wochen jederzeit im haus zu haben
eine offizielle empfehlung zu pressen
und trinken scheint in deutschland rund
um die uhr verfügbar zu sein doch was
ist wenn ein schwerer sturm aufzieht
oder starke schneefälle die
lebensmittellieferung verzögern oder
wenn der strom ausfällt ist bei
empfehlung aber ich sehe es als pflicht
wenn es sogar der staat also der für
dich verantwortliche sagt du hörbar es
kann sein dass ich dich 14 tage lang
nicht versorgen kann sei darauf
vorbereitet und wenn man darauf nicht
vorbereitet das dann beschreibt man ja
schon die krise solange man die mittel
und möglichkeiten dazu hat soll man im
voraus vorbereiten bei 81 millionen
einwohner wenn auch nur ein drittel
treffer ist und vorbereitet ist und es
gibt keine krise dann brauchen sich die
staatlichen institutionen wie polizei
feuerwehr thw und co brauchen sich um
dieses eine drittel nicht zu kümmern das
heißt die kräfte die helfen sollen
können darauf fokussiert werden denen
dem geholfen werden muss also jeder der
ein bisschen vorsorgt entlastet das
gesamte system in einer krise
[Musik]